a long-awaited exchange of prisoners
between Russia and Ukraine has taken
place the swap could be a significant
step towards easing relations between
the countries and raising chances of
resolving the conflict in eastern
Ukraine now fighting there between
troops and Russian backed separatists
has killed more than 13,000 people since
2014
35 Ukrainians including filmmaker Alex
sensoth and twenty four sailors detained
since last year in Russia were
transferred from Moscow to Kiev with 35
Russians heading in the opposite
direction and for more on this story
we're joined by our correspondent Nick
Connolly in Moscow and Kiev Post editor
Matthew Cooper in the Ukrainian capital
welcome to you both matthew starting
with you bring us up to date with the
latest what is happening right now in
Kiev well the prisoner exchange has
already happened here was a very
emotional scene at Kiev but easeful
airport when the plane arrived the
prisoner the former prisoners now exited
the plane they embraced President
Volodya medicine down ski met their
relatives I embraced their relatives a
lot of emotions a very happy scene they
are now likely being taken to an elite
medical clinic for medical checks but on
this end that the exchange has happened
some of the people returned include as
mentioned film director oleg sentsov a
very prominent political prisoner but
also 24 ukrainian sailors who were
captured while crossing from the Black
Sea into the Azov sea in November
romance ushanka a journalist who was who
is arrested while visiting family in
Moscow also Pablo grieved a night a
Ukrainian was 19 in 2017 when he was
basically kidnapped and illegally
extradited to Moscow from Belarus so
it's a very big emotional day for
Ukraine a NIC how is this exchange of
prisoners being perceived on the Russian
side well Helen there's a bit of
asymmetrical side to this because not
many of the people heading the other way
coming to Moscow are as well-known in
Russia as is the case for those now
traveling or returned to Kiev the only
really household name
here Kiril Wyszynski a journalist who
worked and headed the Kiev office of a
Russian news agency apart from that not
many people known to the wider Russian
public and indeed most of them are
actually ukrainian citizens who were in
ukrainian jails for fighting or
assisting the separatists i think this
is less important for the russian
domestic audience than for russia's
image abroad and we saw president putin
meeting in Manama coffe france in the
last month and this is all part of steps
to kind of show that russia is acting in
good faith and willing to de-escalate
and try and find some kind of start to a
new resolution of the peace process
we're talking about household names then
Matthew of course film director oleg
sentsov was among the prisoners
exchanged what is his release mean today
well it's a very significant moment for
Ukraine because he is of course highly
publicly known it's a significant
victory for president szalinski but at
the same time since all of as a figure
who is so dominant and narratives of
political prisoners that sometimes it
can actually suck the oxygen out of the
room for other political prisoners there
are still after this possibly up to
somewhere around 200 Ukrainian political
prisoners of different types held in
Russia and as Senza love himself said to
journalists after he arrived the you
know the fight is not over they need to
free the others so his return means is a
big moment for Ukraine but it could also
mean less attention to political
prisoners actually all right back to you
there Nik because you mentioned some
asymmetry in how this swap is being
perceived so what then is the
significance of a swap like this between
Ukraine and Russia well president
Solinsky definitely very upbeat they're
selling this as the start of big changes
ahead and a and a path to peace let's
have a listen to what he had to say we
need two connections telephone
connections between two presidents and
we have done with yours
instead we have to begin all the steps
publicly all the steps in means process
in Normandy and I hope that I have I
just forgot to say about it to our
journalists we I hope we'll have the
nearest meeting in Normandy format and
we'll speak about it and we'll speak all
the steps during the not the future
during the nearest future we have to do
all the steps to finish this horrible
war so finishing this horrible wars
present silences Lensky says I think
that is optimism that we haven't seen
for a long time this is a peace process
that has been stuck for years and hasn't
been anywhere but I think this is
low-hanging fruit as it were this was
something that was relatively easy to do
relatively small compromises having to
be made on both sides the next steps
will be much more painful this will be
the bigger issues of providing some kind
of autonomy to these Eastern Ukrainian
regions if they're returned to Kiev
control and also what to do with all the
people who serve the separatist forces
some kind of amnesty
what is Russia willing to give what is
Ukraine willing to give much less room
for manoeuvre there and very tough
negotiations ahead
assessment there Nick Connolly in Moscow
and Matthew cook for in Kiev thank you
to you both